they when a real press secretary left
office there was a closet that they
would leave a coat and in that coat
there would be a note to the incoming
press secretary it was still like
friendly and cordial they would say like
don't forget to go here if you want good
whiskey or some or whatever
yeah but I don't know it made me when
you talk about the old phone boots I was
thinking of the traditions of that
office so
people are probably changing the channel
right now they're just going back to
make sure they hear all these things
yeah yeah
no in that moment I just kept thinking
about like I I just my mind
no my mind rushed to like the the very
present unlike what the no earthly way
no earthly way no that is what it is